Stein's representative to the United
Nations says he met with Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez to discuss
Janine and once accountability for
Israel's actions we do not need more
debates what we need action we want the
security Council to act in a different
way we want the Secretary General to act
in a different way and hopefully we will
see some results but Israel says it's
the Palestinians who are to blame the
turn mosques into armed catches as we
saw just two days ago in Janine they
utilized hospitals as rocket launch pads
they use schools and even other schools
as cover for Terror tunnels on Wednesday
a U.N spokesperson signaled the Israeli
raid was likely a violation of
international law the Secretary General
on Monday issued a statement saying that
any military or operations must show
full respect for international
humanitarian law that does not seem to
be have been the case there's some talk
that the U.N was surprised at the
brutality of the raid by the Israelis is
that a correct way to to summarize the
the secretary General's reaction to it I
wouldn't use the word surprise we've
seen unfortunately too many
examples of this uh violence uh in in
past years uh but certainly uh the the
it is alarming uh the the scale of
violence in terms of the effect on
civilians on Friday the Security Council
is expected to meet behind closed doors
to discuss the situation in Janine the
Palestinian representative said he is
urging the security Council to make a
strong statement to do something to show
the Palestinian people that the
International Community will not abandon
them Gabriel ozondo Al Jazeera at the
United Nations